bioelectronic devices from electrodes
that stimulate the brain to wires that
send sound signals to the auditory nerve
have revolutionized the treatment of
many medical conditions in Cochlear
implants metal wires encased in silicone
are fed through the inner ear to carry
electrical signals from a transmitter
but the insertion of wires like these
doesn't always mesh well with our body's
soft tissue sometimes causing
inflammation or damage to nearby tissue
and neurons
researchers in Sweden explored an
alternative to inserting wires by
forming gel electrodes in living tissues
which they initially demonstrated in
plants first researchers tried creating
these electrodes in the xylem which
transports water and nutrients
throughout plants
they initially tried injecting a gel
polymer a long chain of molecules made
up of smaller building blocks called
monomers
they hope the liquid polymer would move
through the transport system of the
plant but they found it could only
travel very short distances clogging the
vascular system
when they change the formulation to be
made of monomers the gel moved longer
distances
and underwent an unexpected
transformation
The small molecules in the gel join
together a process known as
polymerization the bond between these
molecules fix the gel into place and
allowed for electrons to flow through
creating a soft conducting wire in the
plant
most soft electrodes grown in living
tissue required external electrical or
chemical energy to polymerize which
could cause scarring
in this approach metabolites small
molecules made during a variety of
living processes like energy production
react with an enzyme the plant produces
to kick-start polymerization The Next
Step was perfecting this approach in
animals
the ingredients that initiated
polymerization in plants are not
produced naturally in most animal
tissues
so the researchers had to make the
process work with other metabolites
in the brain of zebrafish lactate was an
abundant metabolite
in other tissues like the zebrafish
heart both glucose and lactate were
present for each tissue type the
researchers added in an enzyme that
would break down the available
metabolite into hydrogen peroxide
another enzyme reacts with the hydrogen
peroxide causing the monomers to link
together just like in the plant model
this made a gel wire that could
successfully carry a current
because the injected gel is so thin it
can fill in between existing structures
before locking into place
this soft wire didn't appear to alter
Behavior or impact the growth of
surrounding cells
in the future the researchers hope to
test this approach on living mammals
like mice and fine-tune the gel to grow
in more specific places perhaps
triggered by metabolites related to
diseases
only a matter of time before wires and
probes start to mesh more seamlessly
with our bodies
[Music]